hi welcome to ask IJ episode number 13
and I swear this bear actually is a lot
smaller than it was not that much
everybody's got a question
hi so before we start the show I just
wanted to make one quick announcement
while I was in New York I was on the
Covino and rich show they were making
fun of me because I had so many
followers on Twitter and they that mean
that I couldn't get them at least 5,000
followers and if I don't get them 5,000
followers I have to go on a date with
their intern and my boyfriend here he's
gonna get a little jealous if that
happens don't worry it'll be fine
they'll come through for us so go follow
them okay for a YouTube question you
have Johnny who is asking if I'm related
to Ask Jeeves you know it's funny you
mention that because there is quite a
resemblance between Jesus and I let me
know what you think such a great
resemblance that we may or may not have
come from the same mother so in my last
episode of ask IJ I said I was gonna
start taking questions from my website
comments August Jones was wondering
where I got my necklace and actually I'm
wearing that same necklace here yet
again it's actually made from a vintage
spoon from some crazy spoon guy
you if you were subscribed to
youtube.com slash Oh there iJustine you
probably would have seen that video
already but in case you haven't seen it
here's a short little clip
hey I just een I love to collect
leftover movie tickets are there any
weird unusual things that you like to
collect or any hobbies like to do do I
like to collect anything actually I do
like to collect things I like to collect
pictures of youtubers and put them all
over my wall my favorite iPhone app see
if you can guess it my new favorite
iPhone app game is let's ask IG number
13 thanks so much for watching and don't
forget to leave your comments as
questions ask me questions on Twitter
make video responses and now you can ask
me questions on my website at ign.com
just leave a comment asking a question
and maybe I'll answer it in the next
episode peace